or vous ça incroyable à vous êtes de
plus en plus aimés de plus en plus
considérée au fil des ans
alors maintenant on dit du bien de vous
dans télérama dans les cahiers du cinéma
les inrockuptibles c'est bien vous avez
eu un césar d'honneur vous avez eu quand
même là la seule standing ovation de la
soirée c'est ouais c'était sympathique
oui ça m'a fait plus plaisir même
peut-être que le césar c'était là la
seule qui c'est qui était debout c'était
très émouvant oui vous avez dit ce soir
là je suis heureux de paraître devant
mes pairs moi qui n'ai jamais été autre
chose qu'un un père déjà une très belle
phrase et ensuite j'étais allé voir
votre médecin pour savoir si vous aviez
pour longtemps mais c'est maintenant un
césar d'honneur je suis sympa mais un
petit césar dans la route et comment ça
va ça va très bien c'est pas un peu tard
pour vous la scène un non non je peux
encore assumer celui de la fois aux
jambes ça va non non ce qu'il ya c'est
qu'après j'ai besoin d'un petit est
chaud bouillant
en tous les cas peuvent dans ce film
vous avez vraiment créer un personnage
effectivement comme pierre richard était
un personnage est ici yves robert vous
qui vous a dit ça et vous a dit impose
son univers est un personnage créé ton
cinéma
ouais il m'avait dit je mentionnais
toujours je me souviens même veulent du
lieu et de l'endroit
c'est la même chose je me suis m'avait
dit on nous marchions le long d'une
route du nord une voie ferrée et m'a dit
pire tu n'es pas un acteur tient
personnage ouais je l'avais à moitié
bien pris parce que je me suis mes
pensées l'acteur j'ai compris que
j'étais plus un personnage qu'un acteur
et c'est pour ça que je me suis toujours
senti un peu bord cadre de la famille
des acteurs
alors vous êtes également sur scène avec
détournement de mémoire d'ailleurs le 27
mars au casino de paris
il ya beaucoup de rires dans ce
spectacle mais beaucoup d'émotion aussi
des choses insoupçonnées chez vous un
oui moi aussi d'ailleurs je te paraît je
soupçonnais pas sans ouais non mais
c'est vrai oui je sais pas mais
évidemment je joué sur du velours parce
que je parle de souvenirs avec des
grands acteurs avec lesquels j'ai pu
travailler
la plupart de ces souvenirs sont
extrêmement drôle parce que
lle carmet sonné c'était des phénomènes
et puis bien sûr il en est resté
quelques souvenirs très émouvant
notamment sur jean et sur bernard et
le sort des gens que les gens aiment non
quand j'en parle avec cette émotion est
finalement gelée tous les soirs j'ai
jamais autant penser à quelqu'un autant
de ma vie qu'un quart mais oubliée
puisque tous les soirs ils vivent avec
moi bon bah 7 c'est émouvant oui mais je
pensais pas ça moi je pensais faire rire
ça fait rire beaucoup parce que j'ai
quand même des tas d'anecdotes
incroyable mais y en a une qui est
incroyable c'est mireille darc la
première fois que vous tournez avec elle
est nue basterds qu'elle devait
s'arranger un mois dans toute nue et moi
j'étais relie et elle devait avancer
vers moi elle a dit pire tu me regarde
dans les yeux si tu tu incites on
regarde descend je t'en fous une bafana
tout ce que j'imaginais pour trouver un
bon prétexte pour baisser les yeux et
d'éternuer
il ya des trucs invraisemblables aussi
ces 15 jours parce que vous jouez
macbeth et vous vous endormez sur scène
mais c'est vrai ça c'est vrai et c'est
vrai que c'est le système du tnp à
l'époque c'était de changer deux des
décors s'il n'y avait pas de rideaux il
y avait le noir les figurants en été 20
non nous avons s'agiter pour changer les
décors et leur métal et remettre les
décors la semaine suivante dans un
minimum de temps pour pas et moi je me
suis endormi quand dans l'acte précédent
ce qu'on m'a tuer je suis mort je me
suis endormi et j'ai rien vu jusqu'ici
la suite elle surveillée au pied du
venue de la reine tout mon problème
était de savoir comment j'allais sortir
soit jeu je me levais naturellement chez
bonjour madame
ça me semblait pas très bon soit je
restais coucher comme une carpette
je me disais après tout les divers ont
bien des peaux de tigres pour le poser
le pied l'anfac soldats quoi que soit
j'ai rampé doucement vers la sortie et
c'est la troisième que j'ai choisi je ne
suis pas prêt sur ce soir est d'ailleurs
c'est la pire parce que c'est grand le
tnp qu'on m'a vu on a vu
au ralenti alors pierre richard on va
rester dans le monologue pas faire une
interview monologue
qu'est ce que vous vous dites quand vous
voyez à l'écran
dieu que je suis moche pendant très
longtemps je me suis pas aimé ah ouais
ouais
après j'ai commencé à m'aimer avec la
barbe et la géologie la coupe et pour un
film mais et donc je continue à ne plus
aimer du tout bonsoir vous n'êtes pas
mal on me l'a dit après oui qu'est ce
que vous dites quand vous venez sur un
plateau de télé si je veux vraiment être
frangy merde je suis pas à l'aise
ah oui là ça va vous êtes gentils avec
vous on peut être que gentil que celui
que je fasse aide en général je refuse
ouais c'est vrai on voit pas souvent je
crois que c'est même la première fois
que vous venez ici
ben c'était vraiment pour lui c'est
gentil merci pour lui j'ai dit je serai
grand qu'est ce qui vous dit quand vous
vous levez le matin je crois que je
pense tout de suite à manger oui je me
lève avec la fin je me couche avec la
soif d'ailleurs ses terriers
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
regarder dans un miroir
ça ressemble plus à votre première
question c'est vrai oui si ça vous dit
ce qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
êtes seul chez vous le soir devant un
miroir ou pas non c'est important de
miroirs à vrai dire je suis pas souvent
sur le soir vous pouvez pas être seul
sac j'ai du mal à être seul
ouais alors général suis avec une femme
quand même et donc si elle est pas là je
sors un oui on dirait qu'il ya bien un
moment où je rentre oui
on en revient à votre question 18,6 en
est rien puisque je suis mort de fatigue
et je dors qu'est ce que vous dites
quand vous voyez votre parcours
c'est ce sont des sentiments mélangés
mais comme je suis quand même quelqu'un
ou très reconnaissant dans la vie je me
dis que j'ai eu beaucoup de chance que
je suis un privilégié et que j'aime
tellement la vie j'aimerais bien la
recommencer le double qu'est ce que vous
dites quand vous êtes énervé quand je
suis énervé je dis d'aidé j'ai dit des
gros mots aux brésiliens et pourtant les
parions un reer ou la halle est d'accord
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous avez
envie d'abandonner ce métier j'ai jamais
eu envie dans ce métier jamais jamais le
métier ne m'aura jusqu'à la mort qu'est
ce que vous dites quand vous regarder le
journal télévisé
mon dieu ouais qu'est ce que vous dites
quand vous ne recevez pas de scénario
pas de nouvelle bonne nouvelle le
paresseux qu'est ce que vous dites qu'on
voit une actrice qui veut coucher avec
vous je suis dit je dis oui oui enfin
bon
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
n'avez pas confiance en vos la seule
chose que je me dis c'est c'est un
souvenir de mon grand père sur son lit
de mort qui m'a dit tu réussiras non
j'ai pas confiance en moi je me suis
souvenu ça et je crois qu'il m'a il a
porté cet ultime phrase de cette son
existence m'a toujours conforté dans et
d'un optimisme
caractérisée sur sûrement devenir qu'est
ce que vous dites quand on vous dit que
vous n'êtes pas drôle ça m'énerve mais
je reconnais à à quiconque de pain
trouvé drôle
ouais je ne dirais pas que c'est un con
même si je le pense un peu des fois mais
en tout cas je vous dirai pas qu'est ce
que vous dites quand vous n'avez rien à
vous dire à quoi je sers montréal
[Musique]